[Musique]
la rivière apparatchiks aulas dans le
nord ouest de la floride un joyau de
biodiversité un affluent du golfe du
mexique
reconnu par les nations unies comme
réserve de la biosphère
l'apparatchik aulas a soif et sa survie
est menacée par une guerre de l'eau qui
oppose la floride et la georgie
dalton smith a été le gardien de la
rivière durant quatorze ce cours d'eau
dit il fournit les nutriments
nécessaires à des centaines d'espèces
mais la balade chicola et saab et
manquent d'eau non salées et toutes ces
espèces en souffrent
une eau douce est essentielle aux
premiers stades de développement de
plusieurs poissons et fruits de mer
ils blâment la georgie de ne pas
partager ses réserves d'eau 500 km au
nord atlanta en géorgie une région de
plus de cinq millions d'habitants la
floride accuse ou si la ville et l'état
d'assoiffés ses rivières
la cause est devant la cour suprême des
etats unis
[Musique]
catherine rich est responsable de la
gestion de l'eau à atlanta elle rejette
les accusations de la floride
la région dit elle a fait d'énormes
efforts pour diminuer sa consommation
les pêcheurs d'huîtres de l'abbé
apparatchiks aulas au nom lourd sur le
coeur contre la georgie l'eau douce il
vital pour la reproduction des huîtres
plusieurs doutent qu'atlanta ne consomme
seulement que 3 % de l'eau du bassin
atlanta est en effet au sommet du bassin
hydrographique les rivières tchatat uci
et flint en georgie se jette dans la
rivière appalaches chicola en floride
mais l'eau douce cool de moins en moins
jusqu'en floride
résultat les industries de la pêche aux
huîtres agonise
ronnie coster 57 ans ap chez l'huître
dans la baie presque toute sa vie un bon
pêcheur gagnaient entre quarante et
soixante dix mille dollars par année
aujourd'hui ronnie constate qu'il ne
peut plus en vivre back in the wind aux
délinquants
ici les huîtres font partie de la
culture et se sont incrustés dans la vie
des gens il n'était pas rare de voir
entre 70 et 80 bateaux au large
ce matin-là ils n'étaient que
quelques-uns à gratter le fond de la
baie les pêcheurs sont encore fières de
leurs prises
[Musique]
l'abbé apparatchiks aulas a déjà fourni
jusqu'à 10% de toutes les huîtres aux
états unis et 90% de celle de la floride
en 2012
la sécheresse est trop d'eau salée on
suit la pêche
[Musique]
les agriculteurs de la georgie de gros
consommateurs d'eau sont également
montrés du doigt par la floride qu'elle
s'y cox 26 ans gère la ferme familiale
qui produit du maïs des arachides et dff
soja cette jeune fermière sympathise
avec les pêcheurs et les écologistes de
la floride mais réfute leurs critiques
elle affirme que les agriculteurs
consomme 30% de moins d'eau qu'il y a
vingt ans grâce aux nouvelles techniques
d'arrosage
qui ici peut par une simple commande sur
son téléphone
actionnez ou art et essai arrosoir géant
le vrai problème selon elle ce sont les
sécheresses à répétition dans le sud des
états unis et les poursuites judiciaires
qui ne mène nulle part
le corps des ingénieurs de l'armée
américaine aurait aussi sa part de
responsabilité il contrôler le débit des
rivières à l'aide de cinq barrages la
floride n'a pas poursuivi le corps des
ingénieurs qui jouit d'une immunité
judiciaire
alors qui a tort et qui a raison dans
cette bataille pour l'eau tous
s'entendent pour dire qu'ils doivent
travailler davantage ensemble
peu importe la décision de la cour
suprême il faudra faire vite selon dan
tan 2000 pour sauver la rivière
apparatchiks halls a et la b
oui donc en attendant shannon ne verra
pas son fils prendre la relève
il aurait succédé à quatre générations
de pêcheurs d'huîtres de la famille
hartsfield iris loew nécessaire
il n'y a pas de solution magique pour
monter le niveau de la rivière
apparatchiks aulas en floride
tout en comblant les besoins de la ville
et de la campagne en géorgie atlanta les
agriculteurs les pêcheurs et le corps
des ingénieurs devront un jour mettre un
peu d'eau dans leur vin
s'ils veulent préserver cet écosystème
unique mais fragile
[Musique]
il